the real problem with the secret is the
idea that you're taking all these people
with us that are already successful
they've achieved a certain result and
then you're asking them how did you
achieve that result well I thought
positive and I just really put my mind
to it and I dreamt on it they all have
this in common yes well you know who
also thought positive a bunch of losers
you know they tried and you know they
got hit in the head by asteroids or car
accidents or the world turned bad on
them I mean that actually can happen too
yeah so it's just you're using you have
a biased focus group executive about yes
exactly it's exactly and and the the
idea of setting a goal fixating on it
and ignoring all the haters and ignoring
all the people that will bring you down
is a perfect recipe for failure as much
as it's a common anecdotal story of
success well the problem with that is if
you just focus on the one thing about
human beings I think is that we really
do need other people's input and
interaction the idea that you're gonna
work in a vacuum and create this great
masterpiece without any interaction with
other human beings
that's this doesn't really it doesn't
really work like that it doesn't because
life is active and messy and ambiguous
and ambivalent and I think the trouble
is we get hung up on nouns like
happiness or meaning or even the self
right because I think I think actually
these things are verbs there maybe we
selves as a verb you know maybe it's
something that happens dynamically in
the relationships that were in maybe our
self is something that kind of extends
out into the world and is you know kind
of fluid in that way and Happiness maybe
it's maybe that's an activity meaning is
maybe an activity but we we've reduced
these things to nouns like they're
really neat easy isolated things and
they're really not so I can in the a lot
of the TV shows that I do I'm putting
people through like a transformative
process and they they're reacting to
kind of really extreme situations and I
always have people saying oh I wouldn't
do that I love they but think it's all
fakers I would never do that but they're
viewing themselves as this isolated it's
just this sort of individual kind of
separated from everything else watching
that and thinking how they behave what
they're not doing is thinking and if I
were in that situation when those same
pressures yes what then that's that's
amazing that that does change
that we're not these you know four to
three hundred years we've had this idea
that we are these kind of it all goes
back to like not being influenced by
kings and priests like it was this is
John Locke it's like the the the
beginnings of that that idea that no no
we should not we should have this kind
of personal Authority and it's drifted
into through count I think it's drifted
into a really unrealistic and unfair
sense of how isolated we are we're not
we clearly social creatures